[Music]
michelle is with us in atlanta hi
michelle welcome to the ramsay show
hello how are you better than i deserve
what's up
wasn't calling to ask the question today
um
i want to know how what is the best way
to tackle a depth as a single mother of
a 18 year old starting college in the
fall
and an annual income of 24 to 26 000
and a total depth of 56 thousand four
hundred and six dollars
wow
what's the 56 000 on
that student loan
car total
and a loan how much is the car
the car is 15 000 now okay
all right
wow
um
well you've been fighting this battle a
long time hadn't you kiddo
i had yeah
you raised that kid your whole his whole
life by yourself
i have you're a princess warrior yeah
you're a rock star
thank you so much so i'll give you some
mathematical observations
and then we have to convert those to
real life okay
okay mathematical observation number one
is
if i woke up in your shoes i would be
looking for what my next new career is
because your income sucks
right that's not a shaming thing it's i
think you're probably worth more than
you're getting paid especially if you
went and did something else
that's a not nice way of saying you
don't make much money don't make enough
money
okay hard to make it on 25 000 bucks
yes
out there in today's world okay what do
you do
i'm a dialysis technician
okay
so what could you do to gear up uh some
further certifications maybe in the
medical field that would increase your
income almost immediately any ideas
immediately
i mean like if you took a six-month
class at night
by christmas you'd be making double or
something i mean is there stuff like
that out there
i mean there is certifications in the
healthcare field like um medical billing
and coding
no i'm talking about like
moving up in what you do is a hands-on
you assist in a medical procedure today
and if you were assisting in a different
medical procedure or further in depth
with that procedure and made more i'd be
happy with that if you like doing what
you're doing that is and i got a feeling
you've been doing it a while
uh two years
and a lot of hospitals have
you know
go back and get your bachelor's and
we'll pay for it but you owe us two
years afterwards things like that that
you could possibly pursue here right
yeah okay so thing number one
mathematically agree with me we're gonna
work on our income
because that's part of your equation
there's two parts of the equation the
income and the outgo
so if we get the income up some of this
starts to solve itself doesn't it
like if you made fifty thousand instead
of twenty five thousand uh no kidding
right
you kind of already knew that for you
called me
but you know my point is i think you
need to be actively saying
hey 10 years from today
i want to be making 75 000 and here's
the five steps i've got to do to get
there
and doing whatever that is i don't care
and it's something you like don't do
something you hate but i'm saying go
make some more money number one number
two
the longer you are in 25 000 income
range
the more you have to look in the mirror
and say i can't afford a fifteen
thousand dollar car when i make twenty
five thousand dollars a year
when you have in when you have items
that are going down in value that you
pay payments on
cars
uh anything with a motor or wheels
it it
that are more than half your annual
income it makes it very difficult in
other words your car is a big part of
your problem
as a percentage of your income
so if you made 75 000 i wouldn't be
worried about a 15 000 car debt we just
knock it out
but at 25 that's some pretty heavy
lifting you mean you got a you got a
medium-sized hole and a small shovel
these are my math observations
okay so you can do the stuff we teach
right where you are
but it's just going to be very hard
because you just making month to month
has been hard for a long time that's why
i called you a warrior princess
you've been fighting it i know what your
budget looks like there's no room in
your budget
yeah so we got to get your income up and
your out go down and the more we do of
each of those
the more
money we find to throw at getting rid of
the debt and then throw at building
wealth so that you retire with dignity
so can we go to part can we go to part
three now okay
you got a kid heading into college right
i do
and
for 18 years you've scratched and clawed
and said
this this generational stuff stops with
me
and my kids gonna have something better
is that right
right
do not
go sign a bunch of parent plus loans
that you will never be able to pay back
for some expensive school
okay
okay conversation that you all need to
have right now about going to school is
here is the financial reality of our
world
and whatever state we happen to be in
here's what a community college looks
like for two years and hear me say
my mom went to community college
and then went on to work at one of the
biggest companies on the planet
then got a phd and is now in her 70s
still a professor
so anybody who bags on community college
doesn't know what they're talking about
and you can do it for a fraction of the
cost of of a larger institution i know
this game because i worked in it for a
long time and they look at moms and dads
and say
they will mortgage their souls for this
picture of what this kid's going to get
and i'm telling you don't do that
this we're breaking we're breaking
cycles here is that you hear what i'm
saying
yeah i want your kid to go to school if
college is in y'all's future i want them
to go i think college is great but i
want you to go to a school that y'all
can afford to he can work his way
through community college for the first
two years if it's not free in your
community in your state
so if i load you up with a bunch of
materials
will you use them and learn about
getting out of debt and getting them
into school debt free
i will use them i will use them i will
use them okay because i'm gonna load you
up as my gift because i think you're a
pretty impressive lady amazing so uh
so here i'm gonna i want to sign you up
for financial peace university for a
year
and it includes every dollar the world's
best budgeting app to help you manage
your month money and learn about money
like you've never done before okay we're
gonna give you that i'm to send you a
copy of ken coleman's book from paycheck
to purpose about how to get a better
career going for you
you got to read that okay i'm also going
to send you a copy of one of our small
books called debt free degree
on how you can go to college debt free
and let me tell you we've studied the
student loan mess that's out there and
we've studied it and studied it and
we're really on top of it and let me
tell you a disturbing thing that we
discovered
regardless of race
regardless of income
the number one person that does
unbelievably stupid stuff when they go
to college is if their parents didn't go
to college to shu and didn't know the
way to show them where the landmines
were
and the parents instead go oh all
college is wonderful because i wish i
had gone in college college college
college college and they mortgage their
soul and they sign them up at some
expensive thing where they're paying 15
times what they should be paying for the
same degree and they study the wrong
stupid thing like get a degree in
left-handed puppetry with a 250 000
worth of student loan debt from some
stupid butt school that they should
never been in the first place the number
one person that does that is someone who
didn't have parents in college it's not
a shame on the parents that didn't go to
college they just don't know the ropes
and they don't know where all the land
mines are and the kid wanders through
and just land mines are going off
everywhere and they wake up at 30 years
old 200 000 in debt but by god they got
a college degree which is freaking
worthless uh because you know getting a
degree in left-handed puppetry and
medieval art is ridiculous you know and
you can't do squat with it you end up
being a barista
so that's what you've got to avoid here
all right hang on we're going to send
you all that stuff michelle and you call
us back while you're walking all this
out we'll help you with a career we'll
help you with the money we'll help you
with the kid going to school we'll help
you with every bit of it we actually
know how to do all of those things
you're amazing